Hannibal Buress joining us now Hannibal
thank you so much for being here
before we jump into that not supposed to
be just green
I'm on you good it's good to see Bo
barefoot barefoot on ESPN like a UFC
fighter this is amazing
Hannibal what do you think of it what do
you think
what's that what are you thinking last
dance so far what Maggie is a Jordan doc
so far the last dance there's something
that you've learned from the doc that
that has stayed with you like that that
you that surprised you what were your
thoughts about the whole Jordan Hannibal
what the hell are you doing you how many
jackets
I mean jacket you gonna put on you put
on as many has the segment allows I'm at
home
put the stuff put my backdrop on please
put the backdrop on it's just green up
here it looks weird I'm glad you're just
so comfortable here on live television
on ESPN and on first take you really
brought your thank you just cheering
remember me I was on an episode in 2003
yeah I was the defendant and you